[Music]
[Music]
I don't think I've done one swim in 31
years where somebody hasn't come up
before head and said this soon as
impossible you will never ever make it
and it's not I'm going out there to
prove them wrong but there is a certain
satisfaction at the end when you do
achieve a new and you say yeah that is
possible we can start pushing the
boundaries of human endurance
how far did you get - when did you try
what was the experience like I started
from here so my destination was in fact
the other end of the English Channel
I spent a hundred hours swimming and got
as far as Portland before my my swim
ended and then we had a week of gales
and the continuity was spoiled I ran out
of time and I'm just decided the
experiment was over you swam the English
Channel in the same year as me identity
and did you do before me often weeks
before the English Channel can be the
most beautiful place when when you swim
through the day and the Sun start
setting it sends a glitter path of
sparkles all across the water it makes
you feel you could swim along that path
till morning and but it can also be
brutal because like a washing machine
underneath me back around the plates so
pots names and which is a great start
a long way to go like any jellyfish
loads and loads and loads of jellyfish
being stung yet Oh yep between the legs
it's okay when the waters clear and you
can see the jellyfish and you can avoid
them but when it gets rough the water
gets cloudy and you just get stung
across the face and across the body and
you don't know why except that there was
a jellyfish and I missed it we have had
jellyfish after jellyfish after
jellyfish and the issue with jellyfish
is not so much the getting stung by but
how much it slows down the swim
[Music]
it was great here is that Lewis has got
a cause and that causes the really
important course for all of us and I
think if you have that cause and you
have that drive and determination
everybody can achieve something really
special spaces in the holiday water
[Music]
that's where Steven skipper lights to
keep him because these are dangerous
waters there are people people who die
while trying to cross over to France and
they do like to keep a very close eye on
him as he's making his way alongside the
road there the tide is coming in they've
timed this haven't made to try and get
the use of the spring tides which
certainly pummel him along yes sometimes
he described taking one stroke and the
current taking him another stroke and
that's what they've been seek for
seeking the spring tides have been a
real help for him I guess you'd only go
against nature do you because nature
will win so let's try and use it where
possible I'm so glad we didn't come out
last night so would have been lumpy and
horrible and windy vomit all over the
place again
today it settle down so much it's
amazing how the ocean can get up so
quickly and the conditions in concoct
our secretary
looking to the sea crowds of faithful
wait for me
seagull
there's Luis he's on the team and for
you at home
this starts months if not years before
doesn't it yes I mean me he started a
good ten years ago and finally you know
he's getting the recognition that he
deserves every single day what we're
doing is a bit of a slug in many ways
you know loses in the order doing the
same thing every day it's really hard on
him the chef his chef on board says that
he's prone to a bit of Battenberg he
needs take 10,000 calories a day in
that's supposed to be three jacket
potatoes when he finishes swimming and
occasionally he shouts out thoughts for
his blog that he's been writing for Sky
News occasion he would just shout out
that he wanted back in vogue at the end
so they all had to have the back and
bourbon the Victoria sponge ready which
is not quite what was the intention in
terms of his diet I think strawberry ice
cream strawberries raspberries and more
story ice cream
one of you is made every stroke as long
as possible so therefore we gonna take
less strokes when you're swimming in the
sea you can't do a normal what I would
say pong stroke because obviously your
arms and top of the surface their arms
have been knocked around an awful lot
that's what you tend to do is put your
arm in a little bit deeper that's what
she it's a little bit more to try and
make things a little bit easier on your
body that's about how you replace
yourself not only while you're doing it
afterwards at the same time and without
a support network you won't be able to
do what he's doing we will get it over
and I looked up now and I can start
seeing the Jurassic Coast I had to be so
careful I don't get lured into
excitement because she's still got a
long long way to go you don't think
anybody's gonna crack between now and
over do you think we were tough in that
I started out so I like your thinking
and the beginning it must have been this
bars the start of a journey and the
middle part must have been the grueling
hard part the physical and the mental
side of things and now it's as much as
his hurt and it will be like I'm nearly
there and this is all over and then you
can then actually
[Music]
Lewis how's it going hi it's a bit tough
to slice a little bit but only good I
think another two kilometres nah no so
excited to finally get there to finish
this herb I've been dreaming of this day
but nearly fifty days to finally see the
White Cliffs of Dover I know the day is
the end the team now to be this place is
recycle I wasn't sure I could make it I
really wasn't sure and it's it's a dream
you know channel swimming is not a solo
sport there's been a whole my whole team
there who helped me get here and I'm so
excited to just walk out that Beach now
I've been swimming now for thirty years
and all over the world not just here in
the United Kingdom all over the world
I'm seeing so much plastic pollution in
our seas I'm seeing less and less fish
all the time when I swimming let's say
in the Indian Ocean and I'm seeing the
coral reefs being completely destroyed
when I swim up in the Arctic Ocean I'm
seeing less and less ice wherever I go
now I'm seeing the huge impact with us
humans are now having on our oceans
ocean one plastics zero
[Music]
it's just fantastic that he's doing this
ambitious swim and and drawing
everyone's attention to the crisis in
our ocean because he's been talking
about the fact that on the way he's
hardly swamp-ass to any fish at all
we're basically emptying our oceans of
fish showing love to friends and
relatives or whatever it is
and it just litters our beaches and
tonight I'm going to turn around there
is your husband's swimming in I would
say about 300 meters to go I don't know
if you are you feeling all right I am
I'm gonna hold it together well Louis PU
you really don't have very far to go
he'll be looking a twenty people are now
swimming with them anything that's
absolutely lovely there's a group as
soon as they're loose they've come to
escort you in if you swim towards the
main
[Music]
[Applause]
so he touched the harbor wall he turned
around and he swung me back were two
flags are waiting for him and a finish
line there reads the long swim
it's been a long swim it's been an
incredible feat of endurance but Lewis
Pugh your record holder now Louis Pugh
congratulations can we be the first to
say you've done brilliantly thank you
how are you feeling right now exhausted
and accelerated an equal measure it's
not even easy to get up the beach other
moments thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here's the Environment Secretary coming
in I think he's a modern-day hero I
think everything that he's done is just
so inspirational I think the long swim
has really brought to everyone's
attention how important our seas are and
how important it is for all of us do a
bit to protect them to restore them to
health and to make sure that this
amazing environmental resources there
for future generations what will you do
now we all want to know because it's
very hard to wind down from a project as
big as this isn't it yes it is but now
the real work actually begins I mean
obviously I'm exhausted I'd like to have
a nice good rest and a great very good
sleep but very soon I go to the g7
summit the the the discussions which are
taking place edge of g7 summits are
about protecting our oceans that's going
to be a top of the agenda also then
we've got the high seas convention
coming up all the nations of world are
coming together and saying how can we
protect the waters beyond our national
jurisdictions that's going to involve a
lot of hard work and a lot of bridge
building between the nations thank you
very much
[Music]